[Musique]
voilà bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour
federica bonjour j me et bonjour
christiane le vourch gens essaient
caruge présidente donc de l'association
maison du co 16 du savoir alors on vous
a invité dans le cadre des 6e journée
nationale d'action contre l'illettrisme
parce que votre association justement
travail en ce sens en particulier vous
lutter contre l'illettrisme des
seigneurs saignant voilà alors vous êtes
l'un des organismes labellisés pour
cette journée nationale d'action contre
l'illettrisme une action la bêtise et
donc agir ensemble contre l'illettrisme
sur la période du 8 au 15 septembre
il ya par exemple à la communauté
d'agglomération de l'espace sud eux le
conseil départemental de l'accès au
droit de la martinique le cdad 9 7 2
l'iédom le cnfpt le centre national de
la fonction publique territoriale ou
encore la croix rouge française et puis
vous donc la maison du co 16 du savoir
alors on rappelle juste que
l'illettrisme
concrètement ça concerne des personnes
qui sont en difficulté dans certains cas
voire même en très grandes difficultés
avec la lecture l'écriture et le calcul
initial le vourch est ce qu'il y a un ou
des profils types des personnes
concernées que vous accueillez notamment
donc des personnes vous dites seniors
donc c'est au delà de 45 ans 45 ans 45
ans allant jusqu'à notre droit yen à 85
ans alors comment quand quand ces
personnes arrivent auprès de vous pour
donc avoir une formation parce qu'on va
y venir vous avez une session de
formation enfin là vous faites votre
rentrée à caen et comme les écoles alors
ces personnes là comment elle se
présente et bien se présente donc elles
viennent l'eau à notre local nos toits
de local associatif il lui arrive pas
très vous savez notre rang sur al rai
assuré et nous expliquent leur problème
et nous disent qu'ils veulent ce jeu
veulent se mettre à niveau le veulent
maintenant que
que la vie devient de plus en plus
difficile alors ils veulent se mettre à
niveau
donc on les reçoit on les met en
confiance déjà sous tous importants les
mettre en confiance on leur fait remplir
un petit questionnaire pour savoir à
quel e
à quel niveau du son bien sûr puisque
pour vous dire que les les classes ne
sont pas il ya plusieurs plusieurs
groupes dans une classe il peut avoir
plusieurs groupes
oui allant précisément le profil social
est ce que ce sont des personnes pour la
plupart insérés socialement
professionnellement ou non beaucoup non
beaucoup de noms mais il y en a aussi
qui sont qui sont insérés aussi nous
avons même un chef d'entreprise dans
d'autres associations donc un quelqu'un
donc qu'on peut qualifier d'illettrés
sans que ce soit péjoratif wii qui est
chef d'entreprise et chefs d'entreprise
il est arrivé ne l'a dit oui je suis
chef d'entreprise mais je n'arrive pas à
bien maîtriser l'écriture
voilà alors donc je le disais vous
organisez des déformations savoirs de
base lecture écriture calcul vous parlez
également dilek trop nisme donc vous
faites aussi des initiations à
l'informatique quelques mots là lassus à
l'aller les nordistes s'étaient moqués
sorti comme ça je ne sais pas alors
c'est fait pour cette en outils pour les
électriques
les gens qui ne savent pas sur un
clavier il faut savoir lire écrire
comprendre les lettres au fait et on a
créé un outil pour pouvoir aider ces
personnes à léo aller aux devants à
comprendre si vous voulez les lettres et
les chiffres voilà et ça s'appelle
électro disent très bien alors de
manière plus globale sur quad essentiel
christiane le vourch le président de
l'association maison du coes du savoir
qui lutte contre l'illettrisme des
seniors sur quad essentiel repose votre
méthode votre savoir faire en quelque
sorte et bien quand nous avons commencé
déjà nous avons commencé avec la méthode
boscher que tout le monde connaît il ya
combien de temps d'ailleurs que le 9
février neuf ans en oeuvre un petit bébé
quand même et enfin neuf ans et
nous avons débuté avec quatre apprenants
et nous sommes maintenant à 70
apprenants et encore nous avons une
liste d'attentes pour cette année elle
envoyait un peu voilà donc comme vous le
voyez d'année en année vos effectifs
voilà un roman ça veut dire que ça
correspond à un besoin chez nous un
besoin un grand besoin
et puis voilà donc on commence avec la
méthode boscher nous travelo fonctionne
aussi avec ed des bénévoles des
retraités de l'éducation nationale
il ya aussi des aidants aussi parce que
comme vous savez une classe avec six
personnes ne sachant ni lire ni écrire
un intervenant le peuple ne pourrait pas
y arriver parce que ses pairs il ya des
personnes comme vous disiez tout à dole
pour les profils et à des personnes qui
qui arrive qu'ils connaissent même pas
l'alphabet donc il faut commencer par
l'alphabet les crises au port homogène
déjà donc il faut commencer par
l'alphabet après la fab et le sont tout
ça est un intervenant ne peux pas c'est
vraiment ne peut pas donc ce sont des
équipes qui interviennent aussi à
l'intervenant qui qui qui gère qui est
pire dans le travail en binôme
il ya un un aidant qui aident
l'intervenant principal si on peut dire
alors la thématique le thème général
national de ces journées contre de lutte
contre l'illettrisme
c'est donc le le slogan brisé quand on
apprend le moindre progrès est une
victoire ça c'est vrai voilà donc ça
veut dire que c'est un vrai parcours du
combattant
et donc il s'agit là cette année de
souligner donc la ténacité la forme de
courage
finalement qu'il faut aux personnes pour
donc entreprendre et et aboutir cette
action alors vous vous votre slogan pour
cette édition 2010 ne s'était pas à
pinces perdre confiance
alors ben dites donc nous en quelques
mots le second vient pas à pas en perdre
confiance
il faut y venir y foot faut pas perdre
confiance parce que souvent il y en a
qui se découragent et en a qui sont très
motivés quand même il y en a bien un qui
se découragent facilement alors on
essaye de les mettre
en confiance justement à leur faire
comprendre que c'est pour eux avant tout
il faut qu'ils y arrivent avec surtout
le l'époque de maintenant donc il faut
savoir lire il faut savoir écrire il
faut savoir l'informatique aussi alors
il en a beaucoup qui le comprennent et
ils sont entrés ils sont motivés quand
même il faut le dire c'est à peu près
sur une durée de combien de temps pour
eux alors vous me direz ça dépend
effectivement de du degré d'illettrisme
absolue mais bon voilà en moyenne il
faut compter à peu près combien de temps
pour que steam et que quelqu'un sayah a
terminé ce son parcours justement et
n'est plus alors chez nous les traits il
y a eu 3 qui s'en sortit de
l'illettrisme trois en dix ans en cinq
six ans 3 bon on me dit que 3 c'est pas
beaucoup mais moi je dis que toi moi moi
j'en suis fier de dire que trois
personnes sont sorties de listes rythme
parce que ces gens là sont rentrés ils
ne savaient rien et maintenant ils
savent écrire
elia à l'eau pour moi je suis fier
peut-être vous dirais que ce n'est pas
beaucoup mais quand même et puis les
autres avancent et puissant tir ont
petit à petit ils deviendront autonomes
d'autant plus fier que parfois
effectivement ce sont des pères et des
mères de famille aussi un élément est
bon voilà il ya le regard
alors on va y venir il ya le regard de
la société en général mais déjà ça
commence dans sa cellule parfois
familiale un oui du plus proche au moins
proche
donc il ya ça aussi à surmonter et mais
ça peut la société qui a fait si j'ai
créé cette le regard de la société qui a
fait si j'écris cette association puisse
quand je passais dans les magasins enfin
comme ça j'entendais des choses en fait
des personnes qui fait les illettrés qui
ne savaient pas le prix de quelque chose
qui demandait aux vendeuses et billy
vendeuse les envoyer promener à vous ne
voyez pas que c'est écrit dessus et ils
osent demander parce qu'ils regardent
même moi j'ai aidé un monsieur
dans une grande surface parce que lui ça
fait pas je voyais qu'il voulait de
cette chose là mais ils ne savaient pas
ils savent pas lire le prix ça veut pas
lire et j'allais j'allais aider moi
personnellement je n'ai dit christiane
le vourch encore de questions mais il
est bientôt 7h27 notre entretien va se
terminer
on parlait du regard de la société des
uns et des autres est ce que le regard
de notre société martiniquaise lui at il
changé évolué positivement c'est en
étant par rapport à je crois que oui oui
moi je ne vois plus non la société a
changé pour moi oui donc un regard plus
attentif plus imposée en veillant plus
compréhensif
oui oui oui oui oui oui alors on y vient
cette synergie entre les différents
acteurs 1 qui interviennent dans ce
domaine de lutte contre l'illettrisme
alors je sais pas si vous étiez à cette
rencontre de mobilisation vendredi
dernier l'ajef massy gt oui donc c'est
important aussi
ces actions communes vous vous êtes
bénévole un rappel à la maison du cos
est ce dû savoir bon il y en a qui
travaillent en face à leurs activités
professionnelles d'intervenir auprès de
ce public
comment se passe cette coordination
entre les différents acteurs
enfin moi quand ces noix 1903 1906 et du
bénévolat
tandis que les autres bons se font payer
ou je ne sais pas oui voila mail à cergy
on essaye quand même de travailler en
même temps l'âge j'ai reçu des appels de
d'autres associations qui voudraient
qu'on se retrouve
et puis qu'on essaye de faire quelque
chose en même temps parce que
l'illettrisme c'est vrai mais eux ils
peuvent apporter quelque chose et moi je
peux aussi leur apporter quelque chose
alors on essaye de après la journée
nationale de lutte contre l'illettrisme
je faisais des momies tout à l'heure et
on va essayer on va conclure la sucent
c'est demain oui c'est demain c'est
demain
christiane le vourch questions pratiques
est ce que il est possible encore de
s'inscrire pour cette saison cette année
oui le scolaire 2019 2020 et l'aide
auprès les sketchs a commencé depuis le
16 août
voilà donc on peut s'inscrire en poste
l'année et on essaye de faire des
groupes
et bien alors donc un numéro de
téléphone
oui ça se trouve à 1 rue pauline de
calonne à la manifestation c'est demain
alors non non je porte pour les
inscriptions les ingrédients c'est le
slovène 5000 pauline de kergomard à
ducos cela le numéro de téléphone du
local c'est le 05 96 60 22 58 et le
violon table qui est ouvert 24 heures
sur 24
c'est le 06 96 22 75 40 à la pour les
coordonnées téléphoniques de la maison
du canal savoir qu'ils dispensent des
savoirs de base des cours contre
l'illettrisme pouvoir s'en sortir il ya
un courriel aussi un mail puisqu'on
hugues herbert alors je sais c'est comme
mon prénom christiane c'est point le
vourch alors l'acide en un seul mot le
vosges
l&v aux usa ch
@ haut rhin nord gmail.com ou voilà et
puis donc demain il y a donc une grande
vous organiser une rencontre très très
belles conférences débats témoignages et
jaguar y aura même du slam rapidement
oui à l'islam
c'est dans le local associatif la lancée
c'est à côté du local à notre local
n'est fait le dixième est donc rien de
celui de l'union culturelle de la
jeunesse voilà seul oui mais ça mourinho
caleçon au même endroit là c'est
derrière la police municipale dans le
bourg de ducos dans le bourg de ducos
merci christophe jallet mal à tout le
monde la veut dire parce que c'est vrai
c'est
minutes merci c'était le maître enceinte